Speaker 1: We have now as predicted.
Another new goalpost, another new deadline
from MyPillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell.
We call him Mike Pillow.
The latest is the Tuesday or the Wednesday
before Thanksgiving.
So last month, our friend Zach Patrizio from
Salon wrote this article.
Mike Lindell moves the reinstatement goalposts
again.
Now Trump will be back by Thanksgiving.
That is locked in stone.
Everybody, says MyPillow guy, despite no evidence,
no paperwork and no legal case.
Pillow executive turned election truther Lindell
has revised his prediction yet again as to
when the U.S. Supreme Court will hear his
undisclosed legal argument that the 2020 election
should be overturned.
Lindell made an excited announcement that
his mysterious legal team has fast tracked
internal research, claiming that is thus far.
Imaginary Supreme Court case is now ahead
of schedule.
This is last month.
Remember, this is the big announcement, everyone,
he said to Steve Bannon.
I made a promise to this country that with
all the evidence I have that we would get
it to the Supreme Court.
And I predicted they would vote nine zero
to look at the evidence.
He then asserted that before Thanksgiving,
which falls on Nov. 25, the court will have
heard his case.
Now here, he admits.
Originally, I hoped for August and September.
I asked all the lawyers yesterday.
We're taking this to the Supreme Court before
Thanksgiving, OK?
There is now a new clip of pillow talking
to Mike Lindell just a few days ago.
It's now still before Thanksgiving, but it's
only now going to be that an attorney general
will be supporting this, going to the Supreme
Court by Thanksgiving.
So it's another backtracking.
First, it was by Thanksgiving.
The Supreme Court will have voted to take
the case and hear the evidence.
Now it's I'll have an A.G. supporting me by,
I guess, it's the Tuesday or the Wednesday
before Thanksgiving.
Take a listen to this
Speaker 3: Tuesday before Thanksgiving.
You're going to have an egg this prepare to
go.
You can have the lawsuit filed.
Then you start that evening or the next day.
A marathon of information on frank speech
Wednesday night, Wednesday night before Thanksgiving
Tuesday.
Speaker 1: Is it is this sad, or is it funny
or is it stupid or is it all of the above?
Remember?
After the November of 2020, it's a year ago,
guys, it's a year ago, at this point, it'll
be more than a year by the time Thanksgiving
comes around.
If we survive long enough to make it to Thanksgiving
a first, it was guys between today when it
was November.
Between today, November 8th, I think it was
when the media called it for Joe Biden.
Between today, November 8th and December 14th,
the day that the electors certify in each
state, this is going to be flipped to Trump
or Trump, as some of them would say, it didn't
happen between today, December 14th and January
6th, when Congress counts the votes.
This is going to be flipped to Trump.
They're going to stop the counting on January
6th.
We know how that turned out.
Riotous Q insurrection attempt in Washington,
D.C., 400 people arrested roughly 300 400.
Something like that didn't go fine between
Jan. seven and January.
Was it 20th or 21st?
That was the that was Inauguration Day.
Now I actually don't remember.
Let me look at my January calendar.
It was the 20th, OK?
Between the riot and Inauguration Day, it's
going to go to Biden didn't happen.
OK, well, then they started to talk.
They some said, All right.
It's going to be between January 20th and
March or April.
Others said we succeeded.
It's not the real Joe Biden that became president.
It's Joe the real Joe Biden's dead.
It started to get even crazier.
And then, you know, April became early summer
and then it became Fourth of July.
And then it became August, and then it became
the fall.
And now it's going to be Thanksgiving, but
not really Thanksgiving.
There will be support from the attorney general
for the Supreme Court case, and the Supreme
Court case will come at some point thereafter.
What I said in November is expect this to
keep going and going and going until at a
certain point it becomes Listen guys, the
way to really do this is going to be by winning
the midterms.
If we win the midterms, then we'll put Donald
Trump back in and then even if they win the
midterms.
Trump's not coming back in.
So then it'll be well.
Now that we've won the midterms, let's just
elect Donald Trump in 2024.
That's the sequence.
And there's going to be grifting and trying
to grab cash throughout the entire thing.
Candidates trying to grab cash by saying give
me money to win to then bring Trump back or
to finally deal deal speaking coded language
to really deal with the stolen election once
and for all.
But eventually, it's just going to be, oh,
the way to get Trump back in is to elect him
in 2024, which we have been saying all along,
we knew all along that that would be the case,
so no surprise here.
Mike Pillow as pathetic as ever.